I know this isn't a partisan audience
but we do need to be frank about the
path of decline the Tories have set us
all
and it's not it's not just the chaos of
the last 12 months
there's also the 12 years that went
before it
the austerity which gnawed away at our
growth potential and placed the mess
made Let's be blunt in this part of the
city
onto the shoulders of working people
12 years where trickle down and trickle
out growth strategies failed to deliver
a better future for them
12 years where other countries sped past
us in the race for the opportunities of
tomorrow
and that's what our growth mission is
about
the British people are falling behind
whilst our European neighbors get richer
in the east as well as in countries like
France and Germany
and I'm not comfortable about that
not comfortable with a trajectory
they'll soon see Britain overtaken by
Poland
nor am I prepared to accept what the
consequences of this failure would mean
I don't want a Britain where young
people in our great towns and cities are
left with no option but to get out
a brain drain not just to London or
Edinburgh but to Leon Munich and Warsaw
that's not the future our country
deserves
but nobody owes us a future either we've
got to get it back ourselves claw back
that sense of stability and standing
because when the big questions that Echo
around rooms like this are raised
where does our money go where do our
jobs go where does our investment in a
better future go
I want the answer that comes back to be
a resounding why not Britain
and that's why I went to Davos with
Rachel last year
and we've met thousands of Business
Leaders over the last year or two CEOs
all over the country as I say many of
you who are here today many of you we've
been talking to for a considerable
period of time and with lessons we've
heard loud and clear about the need for
certainty that basic truth chaos has a
cost
that investors need a clear framework
with policies that are always fully
costed
fiscal rules sound and followed
rigorously
constraints accepted
institutions respected and not bypassed
a rock of economic stability
our entire Mission from growth is built
on that and don't doubt it for a second
but
honestly
isn't this the least we should expect
I think so Britain needs certainty yes
but also change and this is my real
ambition the goal that fires my
imagination a new model for economic
growth
growth from the Grassroots
where wealth is created Everywhere by
everyone for everyone
where we take off the blinkers to the
potential of an active government that
sets the direction
and where we come together in a
partnership raise our Collective sites
beyond the day-to-day
deliver the long-term Solutions our
country needs